Oh President Trump is responding to
North Korea's reaction following his
decision to cancel the historic summit
earlier he tweeted quote very good news
to receive the warm and productive
statement from North Korea we will soon
see where it will lead hopefully to long
and enduring prosperity and peace only
time and talent will tell this comes
after Pyongyang released a statement
saying that it would still sit with the
u.s. at any time
for more now on this we want to bring in
CBS n contributor Gabe lipton he writes
for signal a newsletter produced by g0
media all right Gabe so we've had a
chance to sort of get over the shock of
the letter that we saw yesterday and
sort of let it all sort of sink in do
you think that these two men will
eventually meet we've heard some really
sort of heated language the president or
the North Korea originally threatened a
nuclear to nuclear showdown then they
called Mike Pence a political dummy we
heard yesterday in the letter that the
u.s. is has massive and powerful nuclear
weapons and now they seem to be playing
nice yeah look Trump really really wants
this to happen and I think it will he
seems to be saying that it could happen
actually June 1st as they've planned but
I think it's much more likely in 2019
after negotiations start to happen
between the lower level on the u.s. and
North Korea side but timing here is
really key I mean remember Trump Trump
and Republicans face a midterm election
in November
we're likely to see the results of the
Mueller investigation in the next few
months and the Trump administration has
given a temporary reprieve to China on
trade that it sort of sees as a silver
bullet and so the more that this lingers
it's a win for China right there could
be some domestic political things that
come up for the president that make
negotiation and it's much more difficult
now one of the things that we've been
talking about leading up to the summit
is whether or not North Korea and the
Trump administration had the same
definition of denuclearization and
whether or not maybe taking complete
denuclearization maybe they should just
take it off the table because the
reality is North Korea is not going to
give up all of their nukes is is that
still maybe something that you might see
being hammered out do you think you the
Trump administration by ease back from
that definition of complete
denuclearization
yeah we've sort of seen a war of Lords
between North Korea in the US but it's
really a war of definitions I think they
really don't disagree on what
denuclearization means there are a lot
of observers in the u.s. have said we
should take a different approach you
know previous US presidents have failed
in trying to do this through
multilateral talks with the so-called
six-party talks and I think that's
really the format when through which
this will ultimately have to occur even
after Trump and Kim meet there's still a
lot of hurdles that would you know it
would take to you know say remove US
troops from the Korean Peninsula and
ultimately denuclearize North Korea and
that would take South Korean cooperation
that would take Chinese cooperation it
would even take Russia and Japan signing
off on an eventual deal so this is
really a prelude and even this we don't
know what's gonna happen to what would
eventually need to happen and involve a
lot of other act of other powers so
speaking of other powers China watching
really closely the president suggested
that the change in tone that came out of
North Korea was because of China
whispering and Kim Jong Un's ear let's
talk about China's role and whether or
not the trade negotiations impact this
yeah China is really the key player here
right and it sees the breakdown of this
is pretty risky it's given it's been
given a temporary reprieve on tariffs
around technology and steel and aluminum
but it you know but in part that was
because it was cooperating and helping
the US on North Korea now that these
talks break down the big question is
well is Trump gonna go after she you
know he hasn't helped him out on North
Korea but I think we've seen from
Trump's rhetoric this morning on Twitter
and what he said he does want this
summit to happen so he's willing to
allow this to linger and as much as it
does to 2019 which I expect I think
China will still get a reprieve on this
and in fact I think this is a big win
for Xi Jinping because he's gotten this
reprieve on on on trade and he actually
really is more time to contain and solve
the North Korea problem right so he has
been sort of playing Kim to his best
visibility right let's remember before
the fire and fury comments from Trump
relations between North Korea and China
were pretty icy Kim and she had never
met before they've now met twice that's
true so this has been really you know
this has really brought them much closer
together so I think one of the takeaways
for me is that despite this sort of
snowballing and not coming to a fruition
in the way we might have thought it's
had a really lasting effect on alliances
in this part of the world between North
Korea and in China between North Korea
and South Korea in ways that Trump might
not have expected let's talk a little
bit about South Korea where does this
leave them they had really sort of
positioned themselves as the middleman
between North Korea and the US and then
yesterday the president comes out and
says look if we have to sort of engage
in a military option South Korea says
they'll pay for some of it yes South
Korea is in a pretty tough position here
I mean I think Kim I think Trump
president Trump really holds the
president moon of South Korea
responsible for these negotiations right
he's the one who initially brought them
to trump and he's the one who signed off
and said they were gonna be successful
now he did this because he was scared of
that he was afraid of the rhetoric that
was going back between the north and the
US ultimately it's his citizens who are
in the firing line of North Korean
artillery batteries so he wants to he
wants to work with North Korea as much
as possible and he wants us alternately
to happen